I find out that you are serious about
astronomy you really like it
well um yeah I mean I need something to
balance out the UFC thing right sure
yeah
you've got that and the flip side is
astronomy I'm so complicated yes very
layered I I I'm an [ __ ] well you
could always beat someone with a
telescope years ago I did this trip that
I really put a lot of time and effort
into which you know like I don't
normally do this but I did this trip to
Turkey because there was a full Eclipse
happening on Turkey and I did a ton of
research to like figure out where to go
where was the best place to view it
where there was like gonna be nobody
else and like I'm serious cuz to fly to
Turkey just to see an eclipse is pretty
amazing I just I've always wanted to go
to Turkey as well so I turned I turned
the whole thing into like a three and a
half week trip where part of it was a
road trip and I was like sleeping in
people's apartments and like really just
amazing trip right so the day of the
Eclipse I it's like a four-hour hike to
get to this one spot that every website
and every book told me this is where you
have to watch as a clip Eclipse and I'm
I'm up there and and it's there right
it's amazing there's only like three
other people it's really quiet and and
this amazing thing happens right before
an eclipse it goes really quiet and then
need the birds like go nuts
and it's the the light kind of drops and
then this woman started playing a guitar
and singing that four Non Blondes song
what go in a Calypso Simon I thought and
she didn't stop she sang it for the
entire Eclipse just kept singing that
Linda Perry song over and over and over
and over and over again
you've traveled all the way to Turkey
for solitude and you're listening to a
woman sing this song you don't even know
like I I went like a part of me died
that day Linda Perry you're awesome yeah
that person just ruined ruined your a
clip Wow did you not want to just go
like Shh you know like you know I think
I did that horrible thing where you just
look at someone you know you do the look
like yeah and she was just like just so
peace and love and you know it right she
couldn't interpret that as now I try to
give people the look and they always
think I'm coming on to them you know no
one ever I'm never able to communicate a
physical threat to anybody or that I've
had bad food you know they played I'm
thinking right now in young adult they
there's a scene where you have to listen
to that song yeah and I and and you
could was that because the director know
that you hated that knowing that song
no jason reitman had no idea he would
surprise me there was a lot of driving
in the film and and he wanted the
character to always to be listening to
music and so he would always surprise me
when we were shooting he'd be you know
outside of the car and he would just
feed music into the car for me and he he
was rolling and that he played that song
and my face he said he said my face
literally looked like there like someone
farted in the car like it was like
instantly like my nose started like I
was and that's that's your real reaction
and it's in the movie it's in the movie
and nobody knows but it was because of
that horrible woman flew all the way to
Turkey Wow we actually took I heard
about this so we went and took us still
this is the actual moment when you hear
the song
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I that's the look I gave her
yes really you're gonna do this